[Música]
unos dos años se publicó un artículo que
tuvo mucha repercusión en el mundo de
automoción titulado your next card will
not be solar covered su próximo coche no
será solar
bien pues su título es prácticamente lo
contrario que lo que voy a contar aquí
mismo en esta charla
tal y como está planteado ese artículo
su hipótesis es es correcta los cálculos
de ésta están bien hechos y no tiene
digamos graves desviaciones ni sus
conclusiones son fuera de normal pero lo
que no tiene en cuenta el autor doctor
ingeniero de la universidad de illinois
es que yo hace años que llevo circulando
con un coche solar por las calles esto
es en parís leche si siempre existen
algunos locos que creen que lo imposible
es posible
y volviendo poquito a lo que decía este
señor ingeniero
bueno este tipo de artículos
negacionistas es una cosa bastante
normal cuando está surgiendo algo algo
nuevo existe una resistencia al cambio
que generan miedos y generan este tipo
de artículos y de opiniones para
entenderlo mejor quiero que me sigáis
una historia que fui a contar que
ocurrió hace muy pocos años en dentro
del mundo de la automoción y que todos
lo habéis vivido hace menos de diez años
la idea que tenía la gente sobre un
vehículo eléctrico era ésta
y artículos como creo de mencionar sobre
el vehículo eléctrico existían por
doquier que hablaban de la imposibilidad
del vehículo eléctrico y de un futuro
con vehículos eléctricos pero que no
tenía en cuenta este artículo es que ya
había locos conduciendo coches
eléctricos y no sólo eso sino que la
tecnología de motorización eléctrica
estaba increíblemente avanzada porque ya
en ese momento los vehículos más pesados
y más potentes eran eléctricos los más
grandes y más pesados también eran
eléctricos y los más grandes
portaaviones los más grandes rompehielos
son eléctricos
también los más fiables y rápidos si
exceptuamos en extremadura
y aquellos vehículos que además
funcionan en entornos completamente
imposibles también son eléctricos
aún así
no ha sido nada fácil pelear contra esa
ese miedo al cambio y ha habido muchas
empresas que han fracasado y se han
quedado por el camino
y hizo falta una ingeniería aeroespacial
montañas de dinero montañas de esfuerzos
ideas geniales para poder para que tesla
apareciera y diera en el clavo de cómo
comercializar y llegar al público con
éxito con vehículos eléctricos
tanto es así que hoy en día los
vehículos eléctricos como este son el
deseo de la mayor gente de como la cosa
más chula no ya es
en
[Música]
también ciudades cuenta ha cambiado
tanto y a la percepción que actualmente
ya hay leyes en proyecto para prohibir
los vehículos de combustión interna en
muchos países por ejemplo en la unión
europea o sea que hemos pasado en
aproximadamente 10 años de algo
imposible algo impepinable
ocurrirá lo mismo con los vehículos
solares bueno pues mi opinión es que si
un coche solar es afín a cabo un
vehículo eléctrico
dónde
perdón es un vehículo es un vehículo
eléctrico los cuales llevamos a lado
tienen éxito o sea que nadie nos va a
poner problemas con el tema de la
motorización del vehículo porque ya está
ya está probada
y
seguimos con el 1 problema tenemos gente
locos circulando con vehículos solares o
sea que estamos en lo mismo que lo
anterior e igualmente tenemos una
tecnología increíblemente avanzada de la
recogida de energía eléctrica a través
del sol vale ya que el patrón social y
tecnológico es el mismo vale porque ya
actualmente los sistemas de captación de
energía solar funcionan en los entornos
más difíciles más complejos y más
lejanos ya que os pongo el rover que
está ahora mismo en marte bueno
hay 232 pero se me olvidó poner el
voyager 1 que está todavía en un entorno
muchísimo más complejo y muchísimo más
lejos y además la tecnología de
captación de energía solar con ella
estamos consiguiendo hitos que serían
completamente imposibles con cualquier
otro tipo de tecnología
como por ejemplo los vuelos más largos
este es el solar impulse el año pasado
voló más de 4 días seguidos me pregunto
cómo hacía el piloto para ir al baño
pero bueno estuvo
llegar a volar con un avión hasta la
estratosfera y conseguir los mayores
récord de altitud que jamás ha llegado
con un avión ni jets ni nada este tipo
de aviones además conseguir también ya
dentro de automoción en la mayor
eficiencia energética en conducción real
en carretera este es el sándwich de
australia
y por eso estoy convencido de que
ocurrirá con los coches solares lo mismo
que con los vehículos eléctricos que
llegaremos a que sean igualmente de
exitosos pero igualmente será necesario
cantidades ingentes de dinero muchísimo
esfuerzo e innovación para que realmente
iremos con éxito y en eso estamos
vamos al meollo que es un vehículo solar
un vehículo solar es aquel que toda gran
parte de su energía proviene de la luz o
el calor del sol
o de la estrella más cercana en su caso
claro
actualmente existen infinidad de
vehículos solares de hecho casi digamos
que yo creo que todas las universidades
de ingeniería y todas las escuelas de
mecánica tienen al menos un vehículo
solar la de málaga tiene
en las demás hay incluso incluso en
países en áfrica en sitio tenemos de
esos vehículos solares
y yo bueno hace tiempo pues me hice una
pregunta bueno si esta tecnología existe
por un lado y además funciona bien
porque no está en la carretera porque no
la estamos usando
bueno pues ni corto ni perezoso con los
amigos y familiares montamos un
laboratorio de
la materia avanzada de vehículos de alta
tecnología o sea el garaje de mi casa
y allí bueno fuimos descubriendo poco a
poco lo diferente que es un vehículo
solar
um cualquier vehículo tiene que ser
eficiente y los vehículos actuales sean
de combustión interna o sean eléctricos
son todo menos eficientes para que un
vehículo solar funcione debe ser
aproximadamente incluso algo más 10
veces más eficiente que un vehículo que
los litros actuales
en pocas palabras tiene que gastar diez
veces más gasolina vale como lo estamos
haciendo
bueno pues utilizamos tecnologías
aeroespaciales utilizamos nuevas
herramientas de diseño y de construcción
utilizamos
nuevos materiales utilizamos conexiones
a mega datos utilizamos nuevas formas de
conducir auto pilotos bueno un montón de
detalles y de cosas completamente nuevas
de la actual tecnología del coche vamos
a utilizar que las ruedas son redondas y
de eso tampoco estoy ni siquiera seguro
para que vayáis para que entendáis un
poquito de lo que me refiero con esto
unos ejemplos es muy posible que ya el
conductor en un vehículo solar no decida
la velocidad que va el vehículo lo
decidirá un ordenador un ordenador en
base a lógicamente al trayecto a la
inclinación de la carretera al parte
meteorológico a la información que le
mandan otros vehículos a la forma de
conducir nuestra la forma de conducir de
todos los conductores del planeta la
forma conciente de los puntos de planeta
del pasado en el futuro vamos una locura
en pocas palabras para que entendáis el
vehículo solar posiblemente decida en
una zona nublada ir más rápido porque
hay otros vehículos delante de la misma
ruta que están diciendo que más adelante
hay sol o al contrario si está en una
zona soleada
estará más tiempo irá más despacio para
poder cargar más sus baterías no como
hace un lagarto digamos estar más tiempo
vale
otro ejemplo en nuestro vehículo no he
hablado de él pero bueno luego hablamos
en nuestro laboratorio avanzado de
vehículos de alta ingeniería pues hemos
diseñado un vehículo que entra en
producción en las próximas semanas
una chulada una pasada ya luego luego al
final os cuento un poquito más de bueno
en nuestro vehículo como os decía
nosotros hemos incluido en él el
instinto animal que tiene de
conservación de energía que tiene el
hombre haciendo que el motor sólo
funcione cuando se pedalea vale porque
nosotros no pedaleamos cuando no es
necesario por instinto no sea mucha
gente cuando conoce cuesta abajo va
acelerando con el motor un poco
acelerado mientras que nadie pedalea su
bicicleta cuando la costa abajo yo por
lo menos no lo hago
en conclusión los coches solares serán
muy diferentes en forma en
características técnicas tanto que es
muy posible que no no sabemos ni coches
vale pero mantendrán las mismas
características técnicas vale o mejor
dicho mantendrán las mismas propiedades
valen llevarnos del punto a al punto b
de una manera cómoda segura y fiable y
aunque no lo creáis ya existen vehículos
solares en conversación o muy cerca de
estar realizados ahí tenéis el él para
que no funciona es un vehículo solar
parcial quiere decir que no toda su
energía viene del sol pero gran parte de
ella
el muerto es otro otro vehículo fue un
proyecto que por desgracia ha fracasado
pero hay otro ahora mismo que él ha
sustituido que es el light year one de
holanda que está avanzando
esta lección es otro vehículo parcial es
un vehículo más bien común pero que ya
parcialmente carga con placas solares el
modo este es nuestro vehículo es un
vehículo biplaza pensado para entorno
urbano entorno rural para llevar a dos
personas de hacer los recados de cada
día que hacemos todo el mundo
el montilla es un vehículo solar total
prácticamente toda la energía que va a
utilizar viene del sol
y habiendo llegado a este punto espero
haberos convencido o por lo menos dados
una idea de que los vehículos solares es
un futuro muy plausible para muchos y
quería comentaros bueno las que no he
dicho las ventajas de un coche solar
bueno lógicamente las entenderéis bueno
pero las principales es que no contamina
y su independencia no contamina porque
no gasta digamos combustibles fósiles
durante su utilización y no necesita de
grandes infraestructuras para su recarga
de combustible o de electricidad
pero realmente que es lo mejor de un
coche solar que no contamina que no hace
ruido es fácil de conducir que mola un
huevo lo siento pero no lo más chulo de
un coche solar es que cada vez que te
montas en él tienes más gasolina que
cuando lo dejaste muchas gracias
[Aplausos]